*INTRO*
*RIRES*
Salut le making of! Est ce qu'il y a des zombies dans le coin ou pas?
J'ai envie de flinguer des zombies direct, ça va ma couille?
Salut c'est Rick de the walking dead, j'ai actuellement 80 ans!
Je vais enfin jouer Rick de The Walking Dead, j'ai toujours rêvé de jouer Rick, très charismatique.
C'est vrai qu'il est large ce manteau ?
On dirait vraiment le mec qui a essayé le mauvais modèle quoi.
Alors le côté rock tu vois le côté rockeur
Ça c'est du made in US ça se voit
C'est bon transformation terminée.
Norman Reedus c'est moi
Alors je vous présente Julien Josselin
Pour l'instant , ça part plus sur du Kad Merad
Jean-Michel coiffure
ça y est , je suis dans le perso
Y'a une vague de zombie qui nous attend à l'entrée de la ferme
Je propose qu'on passe tous par derrière
Le parapluie c'est carrément pas du tout dans l'esprit de Walking Dead quoi !
J'ai un parapluie OK ??!!
- Daryl sous une couverture ! - J'ai un peu froid !
J'suis avec Daryl !
Ouais , la version Mirelle Mathieu de Daryl
J'suis content parce que tu vois
J'ai toujours voulu avoir les cheveux longs
Et je me rend compte que ... ça me va pas *RIRES*
Bon , faut pas tirer de flèches en intérieur !
Parce que sinon , euh , déjà c'est dangereux
Puis après on peut pas la récupérer
Nickel !
Sinon , on pourrait prendre une batte de baseball
Qu'on entoure de barbelés
Et genre , on lui donne un prénom à la batte
"-Tu vas recevoir un coup de la part de Giselle"
Ça c'est la batte de Negan , le nouveau méchant de la saison 7 de Walking Dead
Coup dans la tête là mon gars !
*voix plaintive* Non mais pourquoi j'ai pas ça moi !
Il faut deviner qui est ce personnage de Walking Dead
Ce n'est pas Michonne
Donc là on est sur les rails de la SNCF
A tout moment il peut y avoir un bon gros train qui nous euh roule dessus
Donc euh , j'ai le cœur qui bat un peu là
Avoue on est des zéro badass
Papi Rick
*RIRES*
Génial !
ça paraît tout con ça mais c'est extrêmement chaud hein
Ça paraît tout con ça mais c'est extrêmement chaud hein
Puis y'a des ronces hein !
Le mec il a aç (ça) et il a peur des ronces quoi ! Qu'il y a dans les forêts .
Bon les mecs , il nous faut un truc nouveau là !
Il nous faut de la fraîcheur , de nouveaux zombies
- Aujourd'hui , je mange que des humains issus de l'agriculture biologique
Beh c'est de la faute de Norman !
Il me dit euh , je t'ai écrit un petit rôle dans la prochaîne vidéo
J'dis euh , ouais cool , mais il m'avait pas dit que c'était 6 heures du matin, lentilles, zombies et tout !
Le bad est total
On dirait vraiment qu'on lui a arrachée la peau
"Non j'ai de l'acné"
D'accord *RIRES*
Et ça par contre c'est des vraies dents hein
Je crains pas les balles moi !
Tu peux pas rire avec cette barbe , tu peux que faire : *Bruit très malaisant* (sans doute une imitation de rire)
C'est quoi le nœud pour se pendre ?
Je rigole bien évidemment !
Faut pas se tuer hein ! La vie c'est géniale, faut en profiter !
Faut déguster chaque secondes
On regrette d'avoir écrit cette scène sous la pluie, dans la boue
BRAVOOOOO !
Trois jours de tournages hyper fatiguant , mais complètements kiffants
J'ai adoré jouer le personnage de Rick , et je pense que je vais continuer à le faire même en rentrant chez moi
Chiao les enfants !
*SOUS-TITRES PAR ACCELERACE*
*Subscribe to Norman fait des vidéos*